[Música]
eeuu culpa a rusia de inventar excusas
para invadir ucrania moscú rechazó los
señalamientos que llegan al mismo tiempo
que un inmenso ciber ataque contra el
gobierno ucraniano
crecen los llamados a que el primer
ministro del reino unido- boris johnson
renuncie mientras siguen saliendo a la
luz reportes de fiestas en su residencia
oficial en pleno confinamiento
analizamos en esta emisión
y el presidente de serbia acusó a
australia de maltratar al tenista número
uno del mundo novak djokovic tras una
nueva cancelación de su visa su destino
sigue incierto para el abierto de
australia del lunes
volvemos con ustedes para más noticias
en esta tarde aquí en france 24 y
comenzamos en eeuu que acusó a rusia de
buscar pretextos para invadir ucrania si
la diplomacia no lograba sus objetivos
esto después de que tras varios días de
negociaciones la otan se negara a
cumplir exigencias de vladimir putin de
acabar con el expansionismo de la
alianza transatlántica y de retirar las
tropas de los países vecinos a rusia
ocurre también en el mismo día en que el
centro de seguridad informática de
ucrania denuncia que rusia está detrás
del ciberataque masivo perpetrado contra
varios sitios web gubernamentales moscú
rechazó los señalamientos del portavoz
del pentágono john kirby escuchemos
tape tenemos información de que han
posicionado previamente a un grupo de
operativos para llevar a cabo lo que
llamamos una operación de bandera falsa
a prisión
una operación diseñada para aparecer un
ataque contra ellos o su gente o
personas que hablan ruso en ucrania de
nuevo como una excusa para entrar y
ganasen excuse to the wind políticos
italianos y líderes europeos se
despidieron del fallecido presidente del
parlamento europeo david sassoli quien
falleció este martes a los 65 años de
edad en los actos funerarios con honores
militares para sassoli participaron el
presidente sergio matare la y el primer
ministro mario draghi la presidenta de
la comisión europea úrsula van der leyen
y el presidente del consejo europeo
charles michel sassoli había sido
hospitalizado el mes pasado debido a una
complicación grave relacionada con su
sistema inmunológico
el actual gobierno británico afronta su
peor crisis a la fecha el primer
ministro boris johnson él pidió perdón a
la reina isabel segunda por dos fiestas
que se celebraron en downing street a
pesar de las restricciones contra kobe
19 una durante el primer confinamiento
de la pandemia y la segunda mientras la
reina isabel lloraba sola a su difunto
esposo el príncipe felipe por las
estrictas medidas sanitarias ahora se
habla de que algunos parlamentarios
conservadores están presionando por un
voto de censura contra el líder
previamente conversamos con oscar
guardiola escritor y profesor de break
college university of london le
preguntamos qué puede hacer boris
johnson para permanecer en el cargo y
qué denuncias pueden enfrentar por
violar la cuarentena en efecto está en
curso una investigación en verdad dos
investigaciones una de ellas por parte
del llamado servicio civil es decir la
burocracia interna
a la administración británica y no se
espera que ese reporte que seguramente
saldrá en las próximas dos semanas se
convierta en una suerte de bala de plata
fatal en contra del primer ministro la
otra investigación que llevaría a cabo
la policía
puede ser más dañina pero de nuevo no se
espera que sea suficiente para causar la
salida del primer ministro más bien es
la masiva pérdida de apoyo popular
la que podría causar el que quienes aún
le apoyan dentro de su propio partido
retiren ese apoyo ya hemos escuchado
voces en ese sentido y si esas voces
alcanzan el número de votos necesarios o
al menos unas 50 cartas de parte de
miembros del parlamento del partido de
gobierno
solamente en ese caso tendría lugar la
posibilidad de una moción de censura
he visto en otras noticias de la
pandemia en france24
después de las masivas protestas del
personal educativo en francia este
jueves para exigir mejoras a las
condiciones en los centros educativos
durante la crisis sanitaria el gobierno
prometió mascarillas y unos 8000
sustitutos para cubrir vacantes y hacer
frente a la sobrecarga de trabajo
los países bajos registraron más de
35.000 nuevos casos de coronavirus en 24
horas un máximo histórico sin embargo el
gobierno decidió iniciar la reapertura
de los comercios no esenciales las
peluquerías los gimnasios y la educación
superior pero siguen cerrados los
sectores hotelero y cultural
y por tercer día consecutivo alemania
registró un récord de contagios del
nuevo coronavirus la última jornada
fueron más de 92 mil el ministro de
salud alemana dijo que busca restringir
el creciente número de casos de omicron
a través de más restricciones diarias y
más vacunas
en otras noticias el presidente de
serbia acusó al primer ministro de
australia de maltratar al tenista serbio
novak djokovic esto luego de que su
visado fuera cancelado por segunda vez y
de que un juez ordenara que permaneciera
detenido hasta mañana cuando hay una
nueva audiencia judicial también el
ministerio de salud de serbia salió en
su defensa y aseguró que no había
sanción legal para quienes rompieran las
reglas de cuarentena en serbia
refiriéndose a la entrevista que
djokovic reconoció conceder después de
su contagio del 16 de diciembre al
periódico francés l'equipe
la declaración del primer ministro
australiano scott morrison diciendo que
está feliz y que acoge con satisfacción
la decisión de cancelar una visa para un
tenista el número 1 del mundo el serbio
novak djokovic estoy asombrado por el
hecho que tales decisiones puedan ser
tomadas por los poderes ejecutivos del
gobierno después de que el tribunal haya
tomado la suya decenas de camiones
esperan en la frontera entre bolivia y
chile para entrar a territorio chile el
bloqueo es por la demora en las pruebas
de kobe y 19 que deben recibir todos los
transportadores para seguir en tránsito
muchos de ellos han pasado varios días
haciendo cola en la fría región
boliviana de tambo quemado con
temperaturas que pueden llegar hasta los
menos 20 grados celsius en la noche
según funcionarios bolivianos la falta
de personal médico ha [__] el
proceso de pruebas hasta casi detenerlo
hay personas que han sido diagnosticadas
y que están esperando a los 10 días en
las cabinas de sus camiones hay hemos
dejado algo de ayuda raciones y bueno
ahora también desde acá vamos a empezar
a distribuir toda esta ayuda que hemos
traído de parte del gobierno central en
noticias desde venezuela el opositor
sergio garrido gobernador electo del
estado barinas tras la repetición de
comicios se reunió con el presidente
nicolás maduro el encuentro se dio en el
palacio de miraflores y posteriormente a
través de la red social 'twitter' el
mandatario dijo que espera lograr un
trabajo en conjunto
barinas es el estado natal del fallecido
hugo chávez y durante 22 años fue un
bastión del chavismo gobernado
principalmente por familiares del ex
presidente
su preocupación en los problemas
la solución
y le ofrece todo el apoyo
constitucional y lento por el pueblo
ordenación en cubos grupos defensores de
los derechos humanos denunciaron que
jóvenes manifestantes cubanos o
provenientes de barrios humildes de la
habana se enfrentan a décadas en la
cárcel en los juicios en su contra a
punto de iniciar las protestas del 11 y
12 de julio del 2021 hubieron a miles
salir a las calles en pueblos y ciudades
de toda la isla denunciando al gobierno
por la escasez de alimentos medicamentos
y electricidad al tiempo que subían las
cifras de la pandemia
y finalizamos en túnez la policía
antidisturbios usó cañones de agua
contra cientos de manifestantes que
intentaban llegar al centro de la
capital en protesta contra el presidente
por la toma de los poderes del estado
los manifestantes opositores incluido el
islamista moderado en nada denuncia en
golpe de estado y rechazan la suspensión
del parlamento por parte del presidente
de caixa y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
usted recuerde que las noticias también
están en france 24 punto com siga con
nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Música]